forschungsteams weltweit haben eine
serie gewaltige sonneneruption
verzeichnet eine große gefahr für die
internationale raumstation ihre
besatzung musste wegen des gigantischen
protonen sturms schnell in deckung gehen
und auch auf der erde haben
sonneneruptionen solchen ausmaßes folgen
wie die gefahrensituation auf der ice es
genau ablief wie bedroht die besatzung
wirklich wahr und inwieweit das brodeln
der sonne auch für uns menschen auf der
erde gefährlich ist jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
die aktuellen sonneneruption stufen
forschungsteams in die höchste der fünf
bestehenden kategorien einstufe xi
brechen alle rekorde
die klassen a b c und m bezeichnen
sonnenaktivität von nicht solch einem
gewaltigen ausmaß am vierten september
hatte die jüngste serie mit schwachen
ausbrüchen begonnen zwei tage später
folgte dann eine der stärksten eruption
der letzten zwölf jahre und gleichzeitig
eine der fünf heftigsten die hier auf
der sonne beobachtet worden war
daraufhin folgte dann einen sonnen beben
von forschungsteams auch koronaler
massenauswurf genannt solch eine
eruption hat die energie von mehreren
achtung milliarden- atombombenexplosion
jetzt konnten forschungsteams auch
herausfinden wo der ausgangspunkt für
die eruption serie liegt und zwar am
rand der sichtbaren sonnenscheibe der
sich von der erde wegdrehte die nasa hat
die eruption mit ihrem solar dynamics
observatorien festgehalten
auf einem bild ist ein greller uv blitz
zu erkennen grob gesagt sind sondern der
option elektro magnetische vorgänge
innerhalb des sterns aus der
sonnenatmosphäre wird dabei eine
gigantische wolke aus gas
herausgeschleudert unvorstellbar heißt
die dabei ausgestoßenen teilchen genauer
protonen können im weltall
geschwindigkeiten von mehreren millionen
kilometern pro stunde erreichen und
dabei auch problemlos die hülle eines
raumschiffes durchdringen eine große
gefahrenquelle also tatsächlich für die
internationale raumstation für die iss
wenn man bedenkt dass ihnen gut 400
kilometern höhe über der erde kreist ein
teilchen schauer kann ohne den großteil
der schützende wirkung der erdatmosphäre
tatsächlich gravierend sein worüber kaum
etwas in den medien zu erfahren war
die besatzung auf der iss hat am 10
september also vor wenigen tagen als der
proton sturm immer stärker wurde dann
tatsächlich den befehl alert also alarm
erhalten daraufhin musste die besatzung
einige zeit in einem schutzraum
ausharren zudem bekamen sie die
anweisung weniger geschützte bereiche
der raumstation aufgrund der starken
strahlung zu meiden
roskosmos die russische raumfahrtbehörde
betont trotz allem dass das alles eine
reine vorsichtsmaßnahme gewesen sei
denn die iss sei sehr sicher konstruiert
die spannende frage jetzt können solche
eruptionen auch der erde und
menschen darauf gefährlich werden der
abstand zwischen sonne und erde beträgt
150 millionen kilometer dazu kommt die
schützende wirkung der erdatmosphäre
und trotzdem hat die sonnenaktivität
auch folgen für uns sondern optionen
formen plasmawolken und dadurch
entstehen magnetische stürme in unserer
erdatmosphäre das problem
solche ausbrüche sind nicht wirklich
vorauszusehen doch die signale einer
sonneneruption erreichen die erde
innerhalb von etwa nur acht minuten dann
dringt röntgenstrahlung in die
ionosphäre ein und verändert die
eigenschaften so dass funkwellen sich
nicht mehr ausbreiten können vor allem
kurz und ultra kurzwellen sind betroffen
dort findet vor allem der amateure
mobilfunk stadt auch gps war vom
aktuellen sonnensturm betroffen also das
global positioning system
es gibt auch einige wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die die sonnen
ausbrüche mit naturkatastrophen ihr auf
der erde in verbindung setzen
taifune erdbeben und auch solche
hurricanes wie er will und immer könnten
indirekt folgen von sonneneruptionen
sein klingt logisch wenn man bedenkt
welch eine starke energiequelle die
sonne da stellt er optionen sind nach
ansicht einiger forschungsdienst zwar
nicht der direkte auslöser solcher
naturkatastrophen doch selbst kleine
störungen der sonnenaktivität könnten
lokale wetterbedingungen demnach
verstärken und es gibt weitere indirekte
konsequenzen die ein starker sonnensturm
mit sich bringt ein forschungsteam aus
den usa hat beispielsweise ermittelt
dass bis zu zwei drittel aller
amerikaner durch einen starken
sonnensturm vom strom und
telekommunikationsnetz abgetrennt werden
könnten
der schaden für die wirtschaft und
infrastruktur wäre enorm und beträgt den
schätzungen zufolge acht bis zu 40
milliarden us-dollar täglicher in dem
betroffenen nächten anfang des monats
waren übrigens vor allem in skandinavien
kräftige polarlichter zu sehen
durch dem dichte und geschwindigkeits
wechsel im sonnenwind entstehen
schwankungen im magnetfeld elektrisch
geladene teilchen des sonnenwinds
schlagen je in einem ring um süd und
nordpol ein da sie den linien des
magnetfeldes folgen durch ihre hohe
intensität leuchtet das land am himmel
auch wenn das das ein tolles
naturspektakel ist hat es seine
schattenseiten denn an den polarregionen
schützt das er
nicht fällt weniger manche experten und
expertinnen sagen dass es bei aktuellen
sonneneruptionen sinnvoll sei
verkehrsflugzeuge andere routen also
nicht über die arktis zum beispiel
fliegen zu lassen oder grönland
dieses mal ging der gigantische
sonnensturm für die menschheit
glimpflich aus ich halte euch hier auf
dem laufenden wie sich die
sonnenaktivität jetzt entwickelt und ob
noch etwas hinterher kommt hier bei
pixum r vater sofort wenn ihr kein video
dazu verpassen wollen drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
planetenkonstellation bolt sonne um auch
ein sehr interessantes video
draufklicken wenn er mehr wissen wollte
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran